[Musique]
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui
jean-marc jean-covici qui est le fondateur
de carbon form
un cabinet de conseil spécialisé dans la
transition vers une économie bas carbone
monsieur jean-claude est aussi le président
du shift project
a paris  groupe de réflexion basé également sur
l'
économie bas carbone
professeur associé à l'université min pakitek
membre du haut conseil français pour le
climat plusieurs livres ont été écrits
par jean-marc jacobsi sur les questions d'
énergie transition énergétique et changement climatique vous
avez aussi un  goût pour la transmission et
la vulgarisation scientifique qui tout
en étant toujours scientifiquement
renversé comme sur votre site
jean-claude.com
je vous rappelle que covey est là
pour nous
parler tous des enjeux de transition dont
nous discutons depuis hier
et je demanderais  vous de lui donner un
accueil très chaleureux
merci c'était une si belle intro j'ai
fini les
blagues à part donc comme certains diraient avant de
faire un long discours je serai bref non
donc  rry
ce que je veux dire c'est que je suis désolé mais
je vais devoir être bref
parce que qui dans cette salle bien
qu'il n'y ait pas de lumières est né après
1992. donc je suis heureux d'annoncer
que vous êtes les générations futures non
non ceci  est-ce que ce n'est pas une blague du tout
quand la convention sur le climat a été signée
à rio en 1992
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne l'ont pas lue allez la
lire la convention sur le climat dit que
le niveau de gaz à effet de serre dans l'
atmosphère
doit être maintenu à un niveau  niveau qui ne présente pas de
danger pour l'
humanité pour les générations présentes et futures
en 1992 les générations futures étaient toutes
les personnes qui n'étaient pas encore nées
donc toutes les personnes qui sont nées après
1992 font partie des générations futures
donc avec cette petite introduction vous pouvez
voyez que la génération future
il y en a déjà un grand nombre sur
terre et il n'est pas nécessaire d'attendre plus tard
pour s'en occuper
donc la raison pour laquelle je suis dans cette salle est que
c'est parce que notre planète terre malgré
tous les rêves de plans d'affaires et de
grandeur  nous  a peut-
être une caractéristique mais elle est désespérément
finie
notre planète terre avait environ 13
000 kilomètres de diamètre il y a 10 000 ans
elle a aujourd'hui un diamètre à peu
près égal à 10 à 13 000
kilomètres et dans deux siècles ou dans
un siècle ou la semaine prochaine ou quand  le
business plan que votre banquier vous demande
de faire arrive à échéance
il fera quand même 13 000 kilomètres de
diamètre
et cette caractéristique très simple
fait que nous les bons
10 8 milliards de bons hommes sur terre avons un
petit nombre de petits soucis concernant l'
espace que nous prenons
et cette petite boîte qui ne veut pas
grossir et il y a deux
sujets en particulier dont je veux
vous parler
ce soir qui sont le climat et l'énergie donc
les optimistes
dans cette salle diront que ça ne sert à rien d'
en parler  climat
car en 2015 à paris c'est-à-dire
dans cette bonne ville
mr fabius ancien premier ministre français
qui devient commissaire-priseur pour l'occasion
pèse son marteau vert frappe le t  capable
et déclare les accords de paris
signés donc l'accord de paris dit que
le monde sera sauvé et qu'il n'y a
pas besoin de s'inquiéter du climat
vous savez que je suis un petit
ingénieur qui travaille dur et la chose que
les petits ingénieurs qui travaillent dur adorent
à faire quand ils entendent des gros slogans comme
ceux du
politicien mr zhadow que vous
allez recevoir bientôt non désolé
je ne devrais pas dire du mal de l'everest eh bien
ils adorent faire une chose qui est d'aller
voir les effets
donc il y a un fait  que nous pouvons regarder
ce qui est en fait assez stupide,
c'est-à-dire la quantité de dioxyde de
carbone dans l'atmosphère,
vous avez ici une courbe à l'étoile dont l'échelle
commence l'année de ma naissance, ce qui est
bien parce que je suis un [ __ ] de narcissique
bien sûr c'est un  une coïncidence s'avère que
le graphique que j'ai trouvé commence l'année de ma
naissance
et cela vous donne la quantité de co2
qu'il y a dans l'atmosphère
j'expliquerai plus tard comment il y arrive
et pourquoi il reste si longtemps
vous voyez que cette courbe a l'air extrême  régulièrement
et si j'avais caché les années sur l'
axe
j'aurais pu vous demander où est le
point qui correspond au début
des conventions climat
car si une convention climat sert à quelque
chose le point qui correspond
au début d'une convention climat doit
marquer une inflexion dans la façon dont la
courbe
évolue d'accord avec moi ici s'il y a
quelque chose de nouveau qui affecte le résultat
d'une expérience
alors nous devrions le voir alors maintenant je vous montre
la réponse
ici vous voyez que bien pas en 1992 mais
1995 dans le  bonne ville de bonn
avec une dame dont vous devriez tous
connaître le nom d'angela merkel puisqu'elle était
ministre de l'environnement à l'époque
donc en 1995
vous avez la première réunion des
parties euh à la convention sur le climat
c'est ce que
signifie d'ailleurs la convention de  les
partis ça veut dire que tous les pays
de la planète puisque chaque pays a
signé la convention climat
qui dit tu sais qu'il faut
s'occuper du co2 et les générations futures
se réunissent  g en bourgeon et c'est un énorme
succès depuis que la convention entre en
vigueur il
suffit de regarder le graphique comment la quantité de
co2 dans l'atmosphère évolue avant et
après la convention
puis vous avez donc deux ans plus tard le
protocole de kyoto où les soi-disant riches
des pays ont dit qu'ils allaient prendre des
engagements pour réduire leurs émissions
vous voyez les résultats après vous avez eu
copenhague qui selon mr jadeau a
été un gros échec
où ils n'ont jamais plus un succès ni un
échec par rapport aux autres
et là vous avez la convention qui
s'est tenue à paris et vous pouvez voir que
pour l'instant
elle ne marque aucune inflexion au
regard de ce qui s'est passé depuis alors prenez
cette petite conclusion provisoire
le succès ou l'échec d'un flic dans les
médias
n'engage que le journaliste du journal qui a
écrit  l'article
et absolument personne d'autre à part pour
le reste de ta vie si j'ai un
conseil à te donner
souviens toi de ceci ce qui est écrit dans le
journal
ne fait que mordre pour  les journalistes qui ont
écrit l'article et personne d'autre
en d'autres termes ces articles ne sont jamais
des sources opposables
et le journal n'est jamais une source opposable
donc ce que vous voyez ici c'est qu'en fait la
tasse bien la convention onu
en ce moment n'a aucun impact sur ce qui est
se passe dans le monde
et je pourrai y revenir lors des
questions plus tard, mais c'est en fait tout
à fait normal quand vous savez comment fonctionne le système de l'ONU,
ce n'est pas là que les choses se passent
ici, vous avez
la raison pour laquelle les gaz à effet de serre
augmentent dans l'
atmosphère parce que nous  en émettent de plus en
plus donc
les gaz à effet de serre ont une définition en
physique très simple
ce sont des gaz qui ont la propriété d'
intercepter la lumière infrarouge de la terre
je n'ai pas le
temps aujourd'hui de vous donner un cours de physique
car je suis trop limité  mais
tout ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'un
gaz à effet de serre est un gaz qui intercepte
les rayons infrarouges de la terre
et parmi les gaz ayant cette propriété il
y a notamment le co2
et donc le co  2 émissions on les ajoute à un
cycle naturel car il y a toujours
eu un cycle naturel du co2 dans l'
atmosphère car il y a des plantes
qui ont un cycle du carbone et on l'ajoute
par des
processus libres qui brûlent des plantes anciennes des
fougères qui ont été emprisonnées
dans des viers  croûte qui s'appelle
charbon nous brûlons également du pétrole qui est composé
de plancton qui a également été
fossilisé dans la croûte terrestre
et nous brûlons du gaz qui est également du plancton
qui a été fossilisé dans la
croûte terrestre
ces combustibles gratuits sont appelés combustibles fossiles
parce qu'ils sont  fossiles ce sont des
restes de vie ancienne qui ont été
fossilisés dans la croûte terrestre,
alors gardez à l'esprit que le
temps de formation typique de ces combustibles fossiles se
situe entre
10 et 400 millions d'années, il est donc parfaitement
renouvelable si vous avez le temps d'attendre 15
millions d'années
si vous êtes un peu plus pressé
que votre plan d'affaires doit arriver à
un flux de trésorerie positif un peu plus rapidement,
eh bien, ce n'est pas renouvelable et vous  peut
considérer que vous avez un stock de départ
qui est donné une fois pour toutes et qui
ne va pas augmenter au fur
et à mesure et vous savez qu'il y a d'autres processus
qui conduisent à des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui ne sont pas du co2
comme la première déforestation est aussi du co2
et par  la façon dont nous avons un
processus de déforestation accéléré qui se déroule dans un
pays appelé l'australie
parce que oui un incendie est une déforestation il a
fait une
compétition rapide génial mais très agréable ce qui a
déjà brûlé en australie et cela a
entraîné une
émission de co2 plus élevée que le co2 annuel de l'australie
émissions dans des conditions normales
parce que
tout le carbone qui brûle dans la forêt
est du co2 qui va dans l'
atmosphère,
vous avez du méthane qui est un
gaz
différent du co2 qui est émis par les
rizières de bétail
, les développements pétroliers et gaziers et leur autre
poussière de lutin et
alors  vous voyez sur ce graphique qui
vous donne les émissions mondiales
nous ne voyons pas l'impact de la convention sur le climat
nous non plus  ee la matérialisation de
l'économie,
donc si je prends l'un d'entre vous dans la pièce
et que je vous donne la courbe sans l'
axe des x
et que je demande montrez-moi où l'économie
commence à se dématérialiser,
c'est un peu difficile de donner une réponse et
le  la dernière chose que vous
ne voyez pas non plus c'est la montée des
variables et la digitalisation
de l'économie qui soi-disant la
dématérialise
vous ne la voyez pas la raison pour laquelle vous ne la
voyez pas
c'est qu'en gros c'est des slogans la
digitalisation
ne dématérialise pas l'économie  il
faut une tonne de co2 pour fabriquer l'ordinateur que
je regarde
netflix a une empreinte carbone aussi importante
qu'une multinationale du ciment lafarge
car il faut aux ordinateurs serveurs une
énorme partie de la bande passante internet
et ainsi de suite et des énergies renouvelables nous verrons que
plus tard,
nous en parlerons beaucoup plus dans le
journal que de son importance réelle dans
la vie réelle,
donc la réalité aujourd'hui est que les émissions
augmentent
continuellement sans qu'aucun processus que
vous pourriez lire dans le journal ne
soit un processus  ss modérer cette augmentation
étant une réalité
dans la vraie vie et je vous le redis à
chaque fois que vous avez le choix entre
croire le journal et croire
les faits
vous feriez mieux de croire les faits généralement
le résultat n'est pas beaucoup plus agréable d'
où viennent les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
viennent d'aujourd'hui si je les décompose par
activité,
nous avons 20 de toutes les émissions dans le monde
provenant des
seules centrales électriques au charbon, donc l'électricité au charbon représente vingt
pour cent un cinquième
de toutes les émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans le monde, à l'
inverse les
deux tiers de  le charbon extrait sur
terre sert à alimenter une centrale électrique
donc le charbon est essentiellement l'énergie de l'
électricité
alors il y en a 6 ou 7% qui
vient des centrales à gaz
et ils sont à l'origine des centrales électriques au pétrole
car il y en a
très peu  plus alors vous
avez six pour cent qui proviennent des
cimenteries seules dans une cimenterie
vous chauffez
du carbonate de calcium calcaire vous le cassez en deux
une extrémité est du co2 qui g  oes dans l'
atmosphère
et en plus de cela, vous avez un co2 provenant de l'
énergie de chauffage, donc la fabrication du ciment émet
beaucoup d'
émissions directes de co2 du reste de l'
industrie, donc comme les
chaudières et les hauts fourneaux du reste
des industries sont comme
11 ou 12 pour cent  parmi lesquels les farines d'acier
sont cinq pour cent, ce qui signifie que la fabrication d'
acier et de ciment, donc la fabrication de logements et d'
infrastructures,
représente un gros 10 des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sur
terre, alors vous avez six pour cent des
émissions qui sont des
spoilers et des bâtiments, donc en France, c'est
considérablement plus  plutôt
25 parce que nous n'avons pas de centrales à charbon
parce que nous n'avons pas d'acier ou de ciment
au même niveau que la moyenne mondiale
parce que
nos infrastructures sont déjà construites
et parce que
bien sûr nous sommes un pays de latitude moyenne
qui chauffe pendant l'hiver mais dans
le monde c'est environ six pour cent
alors le transport est de 14 ou 15
où vous en avez six pour les voitures quatre pour les
camions
deux et deux pour les avions et les bateaux alors
rappelez-vous  ber en ce moment
que les centrales électriques au charbon dans le monde sont
un plus gros problème pour le climat
et tous les moyens de transport dans le
monde rappelez-vous que les
cimenteries émettent à elles seules autant que tous
les camions dans le monde
je ne le montre pas sur ce graphique mais le
l'infrastructure informatique
représente aujourd'hui 4% des émissions mondiales
si je mets de bout en bout la fabrication
des composants informatiques et réseaux et
pour le fonctionnement
4 croît de 10 chaque année ce qui est
totalement
insoutenable autrement dit en ce moment le numérique est
déjà équivalent
au monde  flotte de camions en termes d'
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
manger c'est 20 des émissions vous avez
surtout
des gaz non-co2 donc là vous avez du
bétail vous avez un milliard et demi de
vaches sur terre vous avez
des rizières et ainsi de suite la déforestation
est d'environ 10 l'essentiel de la déforestation
dans le monde, il le coupe, le
brûle et fait pousser des cultures à la place, quelles que soient les
cultures, puis vous avez diverses
poussières de lutin telles que
la gestion des déchets, les traitements de l'eau, etc.
fluides frigorifiques et des trucs comme ça
donc ce que vous voyez
dans ce panorama des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre, c'est que les
émissions sont très liées à beaucoup de
choses qui sont devenues monnaie courante
autour de nous aujourd'hui
comme se déplacer avoir de l'électricité
avoir des processus industriels
comme des objets manufacturés et ainsi de suite
et manger  bien sûr, donc nous ne
traitons pas d'un
problème environnemental qui est un
problème individualisé que vous pouvez simplement
confier à un ingénieur je lui dirai de s'en
occuper je ne veux pas en entendre
parler je m'occuperai du reste
c'est  un problème qui est de plus en plus
lié à tout ce qu'on fait du soir
au matin et du matin au soir
j'y reviendrai plus tard donc une
des caractéristiques du principal
gaz à effet de serre qu'on met dans
l'atmosphère le
co2 c'est que c'est un oxyde  le dictionnaire
est bien fait car il s'appelle dioxyde de
carbone
vos vieux souvenirs de chimie peuvent
vous rappeler pour ceux d'entre vous qui en ont
que les oxydes sont des molécules
chimiques  totalement inerte,
c'est-à-dire une fois que la molécule est sous forme
d'oxyde
si vous ne lui donnez pas d'énergie, la molécule
reste sous forme d'oxyde
par exemple tous les métaux qui peuvent oxyder
les dépôts métalliques sur terre sont tous
sous forme d'oxyde comme le fer pour  par exemple,
c'est sous la forme d'oxyde de fer que vous ne trouvez pas de
fer pur, vous devez donc éliminer l'
oxygène en apportant de l'énergie, le
co2 étant un oxyde une fois que vous l'avez mis dans
l'atmosphère,
il n'a pas de
processus de purge spontanée, donc le co2
se sent bien et  juste des frissons là-bas, vous
savez que vous pourriez dire
et il n'y a que deux processus associés
au co2 de l'atmosphère, l'
un est un simple processus d'équilibrage, il se
dissout dans l'océan, j'en parlerai plus
et l'autre est un processus qui nécessite
un apport d'énergie, c'est la photosynthèse
la photosynthèse nécessite que les plantes obtiennent de l'
énergie du soleil
si vous n'allumez pas la lumière dans votre
placard, ce que vous y mettez ne poussera
pas, vous devez donc fournir de l'énergie pour que la
plante fonctionne
et c'est un processus lent,
donc cela ne prend que  es place au niveau du sol
ailleurs dans l'atmosphère
ça ne se passe pas la solution dans l'
océan est un processus de transfert simple donc
cela signifie que lorsque la concentration
de co2 dans l'air est supérieure à celle
dans l'eau
alors qu'une partie du co2 passe de  l'air
à l'eau c'est juste un
processus d'équilibrage
ce n'est pas un processus de réaction chimique
c'est juste qu'il y a deux
compartiments comme un système de vase communicant
et ça va de l'un à l'autre donc
ce qui signifie qu'il est réversible
il ne peut pas revenir de  l'océan à l'
atmosphère ce n'est pas un problème
il l'a fait dans le passé à cause de
cette
inertie chimique très très élevée
inertie du co2
quelque chose que vous devez garder à l'esprit
car cela structurera le risque de
ce que vous avez à vivre comme il le fera pour  Moi
c'est qu'à partir du moment où on arrête les
émissions
l'excédent de co2 qu'on a déjà
créé après un siècle
encore la moitié sera encore au dessus de nos
têtes ça aura un peu diminué
mais st  il en reste la moitié
après mille ans passe à 20 et
après 10 000 ans ils en voleront 10
je vous le dirai d'une autre manière et comme
les jeux vidéo que vous aimez
quand il s'agit de changement climatique il n'y a
pas de bouton de réinitialisation quand vous  perdre
c'est fini pas de bouton reset
on peut pas juste dire si j'avais su je ne l'aurais pas
fait comme ça on refait
et à cause de cette très très grande
inertie du co2 dans l'atmosphère
il faut savoir que quand ma génération
quand  il commence à prendre des
mesures qu'il devrait faire mais il n'en
fait pas assez en ce moment
il travaille en fait pour votre
génération en d'autres termes la
dérive climatique des
20 prochaines années est totalement intégrée dans les
émissions qui ont
déjà eu lieu il n'y a absolument
rien à faire  que
la dérive climatique des 20 prochaines années
est totalement
scellée à cause des émissions qui se
sont déjà produites
donc toute réduction des émissions qui commence
aujourd'hui n'est bonne que pour la prochaine
génération mieux rien bien sûr mais s'en
souvenir  signifie que sur ce sujet, nous
travaillons toujours pour la prochaine génération,
ce qui est évidemment un énorme problème dans les
systèmes à court terme que nous avons construits et
qui sont remplis de choses que vous aimez
comme des comptes trimestriels ou des cotations en
bourse,
ce sont des systèmes qui raccourcissent le  des
délais d'une manière absolument considérable
ici on parle de processus
qui se déroulent sur le temps des compétences qui
dépassent l'entendement
et qui dépassent surtout les
échéances électorales que nous avons mis en place
alors là je vous renvoie aux bonnes
lectures telles  comme tuckfield qui explique
comment la démocratie est un système terriblement à
court terme mais qu'elle est très mal
équipée pour faire face à ce genre de problèmes
donc une partie des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre provient de l'énergie
et les émissions provenant de l'énergie
augmentent parce que
la consommation d'énergie augmente ici vous  ont des
énergies qui ont été utilisées par
l'humanité depuis un siècle et demi
ce qui vous saute immédiatement
aux yeux normalement quand vous voyez cela  le graphique
est qu'à l'échelle mondiale
il n'y a jamais eu de substitution
entre les énergies
les énergies que nous utilisons se sont accumulées
les unes sur les autres
toujours ce que vous voyez c'est que du charbon
a été ajouté à la biomasse de l'huile a été
ajoutée au charbon du
gaz a été ajouté  au pétrole et ainsi de suite et
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables dont nous sommes si
excités en ce moment,
le vent solaire, etc.
dans l'approvisionnement énergétique au cours des
dernières années, je suis prêt à parier
qu'une partie importante de la salle
va me dire oh allez au cours des
dernières années, ce qui a le plus augmenté,
c'est l'énergie renouvelable,
vous avez ici un graphique qui vous donne
un  variation de l'offre mondiale d'énergie
depuis l'an 2000
si je vous avais montré depuis 2010 ça
aurait été pareil qui vous montre
qu'aujourd'hui encore l'énergie qui en
valeur absolue
augmente le plus reste les énergies fossiles
o  Au cours des 18 dernières années, l'énergie
qui a le plus augmenté
est le charbon, c'est clairement l'électrification
de la Chine avec des centrales au charbon
suivies par le gaz fossile bien
qu'apparemment certains disent que ça va devenir
vert
puis suivi par le pétrole et ce que vous voyez
c'est que le  le vent et le soleil sont loin
derrière
et en fait si les nouvelles avaient une pagination
proportionnelle à ce qui s'est passé
dans le monde au cours des 18 dernières années
eh bien pour chaque article sur le solaire
ils auraient dû être fait 11 sur le froid
dont je ne me souviens pas  eux faisant ça
et vous savez une histoire amusante à propos des
moulins à vent que nous connaissons depuis
2000 ans,
nous avions des repas d'eau dans tout l'
empire romain,
il y a 2 000 ans, l'énergie éolienne était
très connue
et si l'énergie éolienne est tellement meilleure que
fossile  carburants,
c'est ce que certains de ses produits
disent aujourd'hui
pourquoi avons-nous pris la peine de passer de l'éolien aux
combustibles
fossiles c'était beaucoup mieux eh bien il n'y
avait aucune raison de le faire en
fait quand vous regardez  histoire on se
rend compte que ce qui s'est passé est l'
exact
opposé de ce qui est parfois présenté
comme une évidence il y a quelques siècles on
avait une marine 100 renouvelable
voici un bateau 100 renouvelable fait d'
un bois renouvelable avec du coton
et du linol renouvelables dit
conduit par des marins parfaitement renouvelables
et les galériens aussi
parfois ils avaient aussi un scorbut renouvelable
mais on a dit non en fait pour approvisionner
le supermarché du coin pour pas cher
c'est bien mieux d'avoir une
marina fossilisée donc on va fossiliser la
marine on avait des transports terrestres parfaitement renouvelables
voici une charrette en bois renouvelable  d'accord non
je triche il y a probablement deux ou
trois raccords là-dedans il n'y a rien
avec un cheval nervable mangeant de
l'herbe renouvelable
encore pour remplir le supermarché de vente
comme s'il valait mieux le fossiliser
nous avions une agriculture renouvelable avec
des tracteurs renouvelables qui sont  appelés bœufs
et chevaux de trait
c'est pourquoi ils étaient des boucheries de chevaux
au fait et ils mangeaient de
l'herbe renouvelable et ainsi de suite  n
et donc nous avons dit non pour avoir des
mcdonald's bon marché ou toute autre marque qui s'en soucie
ça va être bien mieux si nous utilisons l'
agriculture à base de fossiles
nous avions des travaux publics qui étaient renouvelables
il a fallu un peu plus de temps pour faire les
voies romaines bien sûr mais c'est  la vie
maintenant pour faire des ronds-points et les français sont
vraiment importants
nous utilisons des chargeuses-pelleteuses fossiles parce que
c'est plus efficace
nous avions une construction renouvelable donc il a fallu
un bon siècle pour faire notre dame
version un
bien sûr la version deux va être plus rapide
aujourd'hui pour faire de gros bâtiments en forme de cornichon
a la defense d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien psychanalyser l'architecte
on va beaucoup plus vite grace a l'
energie fossile on avait de l'industrie renouvelable
comme tu vois avec ce
moulin a eau renouvelable
on s'est dit tu sais faire des jouets de noel pas cher
c'est beaucoup mieux  avoir une
industrie fossilisée donc on l'a fossilisée
on avait même des séchoirs renouvelables qui
s'appelaient le soleil mais maintenant on a des
gastrites donc ça fait deux
siècles qu'on fait  l'exact
opposé de ce qui est présenté aujourd'hui comme
une évidence
sur le plan économique sur le
plan écologique on entend des trucs comme les
renouvelables c'est l'avenir ils sont pas chers
et cetera
sauf que ça fait exactement deux
siècles qu'on a fait exactement l'
inverse
donc là  ça doit être une petite raison qui est
physique
donc pour comprendre cette raison physique
on va faire un petit détour par
la tour eiffel
qui a déjà monté la tour eiffel
pas avec l'ascenseur à pied en prenant les
escaliers
donc mon calcul fonctionne que tu fais
six fois de suite alors imaginez que vous
grimpez
six fois de suite et bien cette dame ici
pèse probablement moins de 80
kilogrammes mais cela n'a pas d'importance mon
calcul fonctionne dans des ordres de grandeur
donc vous le faites six fois de suite avec un
petit pique-nique dans ton sac à dos
qui te fait gravir 2000 mètres ou
7000 pieds en une journée
tu vas faire ça avec tes jambes
et tes jambes vont évidement
fournir de l'énergie
l'énergie que ça me fournit  s soulever
votre corps contre le
champ gravitationnel c'est ce qu'ils font
bien en faisant cet exercice que normalement
vous ne faites pas tous les jours
vous allez fournir une
énergie mécanique qui a l'odeur d'
un demi kilowattheure ou d'un virgule
million  joules
qui est ce que vous allez fournir
avec vos jambes avec un jour de forte
sueur si vous faites cela tous les deux jours,
donc à la fin de l'année, vous serez
super entraîné et saluerez leurs
courses comme celle-ci, vous savez  montez les
phares des bâtiments de
toute façon vous serez très bien entraînés et
à la fin de l'année
vos jambes auront fourni l'
énergie mécanique de l'ovateur de 100 kilowattheures
donc c'est ce qu'il faut garder à l'esprit
un homme en premier travail
handicapé chaque année en utilisant  les muscles les plus
puissants que sont
ses jambes pour fournir 100 kilowattheures
de moteur mécanique
si vous prenez mon ouvrier des travaux publics
des temps anciens et lui faites creuser quelques
tonnes de terre
pendant la journée donc par exemple j'ai pris six
met cube  ers c'est pour sauver
15 tonnes pas mal il va avoir de belles
cloques et mal au dos en fin
de journée
et il le surélève d'un mètre et il
va être 10 fois plus ridicule
que le grimpeur de la tour eiffel et
fournir 0,05 kilowatt  heures d'
énergie mécanique
s'il le fait tous les deux jours 10
kilowattheures pendant un an,
donc à ce stade, 10 100
kilowattheures ne signifient peut-être pas grand-chose
où cela signifiera quelque chose, c'est
que si vous brûlez un litre d'essence,
ce qui, comme vous le savez, est moyen  trop cher
comme le disent les gilets jaunes
eh bien si vous brûlez un litre d'essence
vous dégagerez
10 kilowattheures d'énergie thermique donc
quand ça passe une fois qu'il passe par le
moteur il vous restera deux à quatre
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
donc dedans  un litre d'essence qui coute le
prix exorbitant
d'un an ou quelque chose tu as la
même capacité à transformer l'
environnement qu'avec 10 à 100 jours de travail forcé
d'un être humain
si insensible au fait que la france
i  c'est un pays 100% nucléaire comme disent certains
chaque français consomme
plusieurs centaines de litres d'essence en
moyenne chaque année
de l'ordre de 600. maintenant si on
parle d'argent car c'est la
seule chose qui vous intéresse dans cette
université
si vous  prends mon ouvrier mon esclave mon
fournisseur d'énergie mécanique
tu verras en fait je vais t'expliquer
en parlant d'argent c'est pas
intéressant
c'est un problème c'est une
convention extrêmement réductrice de ce qui se passe
dans le monde
si tu payes celui qui fournit  vous
l'énergie qui est la transformation
du monde au SMIC
vous paierez votre kilowattheure d'
énergie mécanique entre cent
et mille euros alors que la
machine vous rend le même service avec un
coût marginal de quelques dizaines de
centimes autrement dit quand vous  passer de l'homme à la
machine
et c'est exactement pourquoi nous avons été des
énergies renouvelables
c'est exactement pourquoi nous les avons abandonnées
vous êtes en mesure de fournir
pour diviser le coût d'une
transformation unitaire  ation dans l'environnement
de quelques centaines à quelques milliers
c'est le coût
de passer de la laine à un pull d'une
fibre textile à un vêtement des
minerais métalliques aux chaises etc
tout cela a été divisé par quelques
centaines à quelques milliers
grâce à l'avènement des machines et de l'
énergie donc ce que je vous dis
c'est quelque chose de très simple que votre
pouvoir d'achat
et le mien et celui de tous les français et
de chaque personne dans le monde
aujourd'hui est basé sur l'énergie c'est ce que l'
énergie nous a apporté
le  explosion de notre pouvoir d'achat, les
gens n'étaient pas plus bêtes avant que nous
découvrions les combustibles fossiles, vous savez,
certains étaient encore plus intelligents que n'importe qui dans
cette salle,
mais ils n'avaient pas de combustibles fossiles à leur
disposition, ils n'avaient donc pas de
pouvoir d'achat pour tout le monde,
ce qui faisait du pouvoir d'achat  car tout était
énergie
c'est même ce qui a libéré les esclaves si tu
prends un esclave ce qui normalement n'est pas une
vocation de jeunesse sauf pour quelques
personnes qui ne le crient pas sur les toits
tu vas devoir y aller  d obtenir cette
personne contre son gré
ce qui va vous coûter de l'argent le
nourrir car sinon vous perdrez
vos avoirs l'
empêcher de vous tuer comme dans
django qui va vous coûter de l'argent
et l'empêcher de [ __ ] le camp
de là  ou les deux en même temps
comme dans django
donc si vous cumulez tous les frais de
possession d'un esclave
qui va rendre votre service vous vous
rendez compte que ça va vous coûter
10 à 100 fois plus cher que la machine
qui n'en fait pas partie  le syndicat parfois
le conducteur oui mais pas la machine
qui travaille 24h/24 et qui n'a
absolument rien contre sa condition
de machine
donc la raison pour laquelle on est passé de l'homme
à la machine
et des énergies renouvelables qui sont
bien moins denses que les énergies fossiles
trop les énergies fossiles c'est parce que ça
nous a permis d'augmenter
indéfiniment notre costume de superman donc
aujourd'hui l'
énergie représente en fait notre
costume de superman ou iron man
ce n'est pas un costume qu'on met
le matin un  d la lumière
brille au milieu mais en fait c'est
un costume d'homme de fer
qui est composé de tous les trains les
avions la machine à laver les
moulins régnants la cimenterie les tracteurs les
moissonneuses-batteuses
machines frigorifiques etc bref toutes
les machines que nous sommes actuellement
avoir dans le monde et qui fonctionnent pour nous
pendant que nous sommes occupés à raconter des histoires dans cette
pièce
parce que c'est ce que nous faisons nous nous
racontons des histoires dans cette pièce
pendant que les machines fonctionnent et
qu'elles préparent notre nourriture
si je  regardez la puissance des machines
installées dans le monde aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire toutes les machines dont
j'ai parlé en plus de celles dont je
n'ai pas parlé
mangent leur propre nourriture qui s'appelle
bien énergétique à tout moment dans le
monde  la puissance
des machines en fonctionnement est plusieurs
centaines de fois la puissance musculaire de l'
humanité
et le monde occidental est plus proche du
millier donc ce que je vous dis
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la production ne se fait pas
b  y les gens mais c'est fait par les machines
donc ce qui fera le succès de votre
business plan ce ne sont pas les gens mais les machines
la raison pour laquelle le pib français a été
temporairement supérieur
au pib chinois alors que les chinois
ont toujours été considérablement plus que
les français c'est parce que
il fut un temps où les français avaient
plus de machines que la
période chinoise ce qui fait la production et j'y
reviendrai plus tard ce sont les machines
donc ça vient un peu en opposition
avec les cours d'économie que vous apprenez
ici
les cours d'économie que vous apprenez ici sont
basé sur un postulat
qui a été avancé il y a deux siècles
par un certain nombre d'économistes
dont monsieur jean-baptiste dites ce que vous
avez ici
et ces économistes ont dit que la nature
vaut zéro
ok ce que la nature nous donne est gratuit
alors je vais prendre un exemple idiot  il y a 20
pour cent d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère
si je sors les 20 puits, alors
soyons clairs que ces 20 d'oxygène
ne sont à aucun compte de
profits et pertes d'une
entreprise dont  plan d'affaires que vous allez
convenir que vous n'avez jamais vu une ligne de charge
avec l'oxygène dans l'air et
bien je ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu
peut-être que vous devriez arrêter de boire
sinon non donc c'est gratuit parce que ce n'est
pas  dans n'importe quelle ligne de charge,
sauf que si je retire l'oxygène de
là, vous mourrez tous, il n'y aura plus d'
entreprises, plus de comptes de profits et pertes
, etc.,
donc c'est quelque chose de gratuit et d'
essentiel et en fait, tout sur
terre est gratuit et essentiel
le système climatique est gratuit et indispensable
l'existence des océans est gratuite et
indispensable et ainsi de suite
pour qu'on puisse s'amuser à regarder combien
ça vaut tout ça je vais vous donner ce petit
calcul que je trouve marrant
vous avez là la deuxième patrie des français
l'astronaute m. tomapeski
c'est-à-dire la station spatiale internationale
donc la station spatiale internationale
vaut
100 milliards de dollars et c'est un
appartement capable de loger six personnes
ce qui signifie qu'il vaut 15 milliards de
dollars par personne tout le monde en grèce
donc wh  c'est l'utilisation de la
station spatiale internationale elle
crée dans un endroit où elle n'existe pas une
pression d'un bar d'
air respirable et un début de
cycle de l'eau
c'est tout ce qu'elle peut faire on ne peut même pas
faire pousser des carottes
on ne peut pas frotter la carotte  là-haut, il
ne pousse pas de champs de blé, vous ne pouvez même
pas manger de poisson, rien de tout cela n'existe
là-haut,
cela crée simplement un
air respirable à pression atmosphérique au début d'un
cycle de l'eau
qui vaut 15 milliards par
personne  vous dire que la planète Terre qui
nous donne une atmosphère respirable
la pression d'un forage au niveau du sol
un cycle de l'eau et bien
plus puisque nous pouvons attraper des poissons faire pousser des
carottes faire une promenade
sur la plage ça vaut au moins 15
milliards de dollars par personne
donc si  vous prenez la fraction de planète
que nous détruisons chaque année
pour alimenter notre système économique c'est au
moins un pour mille
ce qui veut dire que chaque année nous détruisons
au moins un pour mille les
stocks de poissons les stocks de pétrole le gaz les avirons
les spe  cies et ainsi de suite alors le comptable
passe
et dit que pendant que vous détruisez un
millième de quelque chose de
15 milliards de monde, vous allez m'avoir une
allocation dépréciée de 15 millions par
an et par personne
, d'un autre côté, vous avez un pib qui est
ça vaut 15 000
par personne et par an donc tu vois j'explique
que si on prend une convention économique
qui n'est pas plus stupide qu'une autre
notre économie est une machine à perdre pour bruler de l'
argent qu'on n'a pas
et qu'on n'a pas  riche en fait c'est une
machine à bruler du
cash mille fois plus vite du côté de
ce qu'on perd mais du côté de ce qu'on
gagne
avec une simple convention économique
dérivée du coût de la
station spatiale internationale
donc le fait que notre économie aujourd'hui est  un
système rentable
pour les gens est une vision conventionnelle ce n'est
pas une réalité
la réalité est qu'il y a un
confort matériel à court terme
mais le fait que l'équilibre global à long terme
est une bonne affaire
c'est clairement conventionnel alors permettez-moi de
reformuler
nous considérons e  à la nature est libre et
donc infinie
c'est ce que disait monsieur say et donc si
c'est infini ça ne peut pas être un
facteur limitant d'un système productif
il dit que les deux facteurs limitants de la
production sont le travail humain et le capital humain
cela suffit pour remplir le supermarché
donc  toute personne qui passe et qui s'intéresse
aux flux physiques vous dira
euh pour remplir le supermarché il se peut que vous ayez besoin
d'avoir des ressources pour fabriquer les produits
au supermarché c'est compliqué d'
aller chez zaha si zara c'est que
vous avez le concept de vêtements c'est mieux
s'ils  vous vendre de
vrais vêtements pour que ces vêtements soient
faits de matériaux ces matériaux dont vous avez besoin
pour trouver quelque part ils s'appellent des
ressources
et c'est soit des fibres végétales ou un
morceau d'huile si vous portez des
fibres synthétiques comme n'importe qui dans cette pièce qui porte
des fibres synthétiques est  porter du pétrole,
alors vous devez avoir la capacité de
transformer ces
ressources en travail et cette capacité de
transformer les ressources
est faite pour une très petite partie  avec les
muscles des hommes et la majeure partie
est transformée par les machines dans cette
histoire le
capital est une simple boucle intérieure du
système
car ce bâtiment qui est un
élément du capital a été fait exactement de la
même manière que vos chaussettes transformant
les ressources naturelles
entendues de la même manière physique  processus
là vous comprenez qu'il y a d'
autres facteurs limitants qui entrent en
jeu
si vous n'avez pas assez d'énergie pour alimenter
les machines je peux
avoir beaucoup de gens qui acceptent de se lever
le matin parce que mr mchonk les a
frustrés et beaucoup de
gentil banquier très sympa à investir car mme lagat les
a persuadés
si je n'ai pas assez d'énergie pour faire fonctionner les
machines je n'aurai pas assez de
pib
même s'il y a beaucoup d'hommes et de
banquiers compatissants et si je n'ai pas
assez de ressources pour transformer les
mêmes résultats même si j'en ai assez
c'est encore aujourd'hui le premier
facteur limitant de l'activité économique
donc je vous présente et ne vais pas aux cours d'
économie macroéconomique c'est n  o
utiliser
voici le seul modèle macroéconomique que
vous devez garder à l'esprit
car il fonctionne très très bien et il
a toujours bien fonctionné depuis que j'ai commencé à l'
utiliser
le modèle macro économique que je vous présente
dit que le pib
dans le monde donc c'est à  disons que la
valeur économique des ressources qui
ont été transformées
parce que c'est bien le pib est une
fonction quasi-linéaire
de la quantité d'énergie que nous utilisons c'est-
à-dire pour économiser un certain nombre de machines en
fonctionnement
alors comptez le nombre de machines en
fonctionnement qui est mesuré par  de l'énergie
et vous avez de la production
et vous avez terminé plus besoin que je vous embête
mais cela amène au drame des négociations climatiques
puisque le gros de cette énergie est fossile au
fur et à mesure et comme nous allons le voir
bientôt nous allons  pas sur le point de changer si bien que
nous avons la même
relation quasi linéaire entre le pib
et le co2,
donc la très très bonne nouvelle que j'apporte ici
aujourd'hui est que pour nous, pour
résoudre le problème climatique, la
plupart de vos plans d'affaires vont
n  Dois-je être en phase avec une récession
dois-je répéter ou tout le monde a-t
-il très bien compris
c'est ce que cela signifie de surmonter le
problème climatique
si nous le faisons, nous avons une très petite
chance
et nous verrons le rythme pour rester en dessous  les
deux degrés si nous ne le faisons pas,
nous dépasserons les deux degrés et les
choses vont être régulées par un
désastre qui fonctionne très bien comme l'
histoire l'a montré,
donc l'histoire des 20e et 19e
siècles est très très simple
nous avons  des combustibles fossiles souterrains qui
sont gratuits comme toutes les ressources naturelles, donc le
pétrole est aussi
gratuit que le vent, personne dans cette salle n'a
rien payé pour que le pétrole forme
ces combustibles fossiles fournissent un
approvisionnement énergétique qui nous donne la capacité de
transformer n'importe quoi
et qui est également gratuit par  le chemin et cela
nous a permis de faire de toutes les choses
qui nous entourent le système économique social
qui est à la base de la productivité du travail
qui n'est rien de plus que des
machines attachées aux personnes
l'augmentation de la productivité du travail n'est pas
la  au moment où vous vous êtes transformé en shiva avec 253
bras et 96 jambes,
c'est juste que nous avons ajouté des machines qui
fonctionnent pour vous
mais nous avons laissé les hommes dans le dénominateur donc
c'est juste un artefact normatif
le fait que la productivité du travail a
augmenté votre puissance musculaire  n'a pas
augmenté à
droite et euh nous
sommes habitués à rendre compte de ce que nous faisons
économiquement et à l'appeler pib
donc il y a beaucoup de facteurs limitants que vous
ne pouvez pas appliquer comme je l'ai dit plus tôt
voici deux sur lesquels je détaillerai plus en détail
le premier est le climat  changement qui est un
facteur limitant s'il y en a
trop va empêcher le système de fonctionner
correctement
et il y a un deuxième facteur limitant
qui est déjà à l'œuvre en europe qui
est un goulot d'étranglement sur l'
approvisionnement en énergie fossile c'est-à-dire que l'énergie
des énergies fossiles
ben vu qu'ils ne sont pas éternels où
tu ne peux pas éternellement en extraire de plus en
plus
il y a un moment où tu commences à
avoir des problèmes pour être plus précis si
tu consommes à partir d'un stock de départ qui
est donné une fois par an  d pour tout ce qui est le
cas pour le pétrole le gaz et le charbon
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que vous ne pouvez pas avoir
une extraction indéfiniment croissante
de ce stock les
mathématiques vous l'interdisent vous ne
pouvez même pas avoir une
instruction indéfiniment constante de ce stock les
mathématiques aussi l'interdisent
en fait  les mathématiques vous obligent à avoir une
extraction qui ressemble à ça
c'est-à-dire qu'elle part de zéro
si vous allez assez loin dans le passé ce qui
se vérifie facilement elle finira à
zéro si vous allez assez loin dans le
futur
aussi facilement démontré  scénario du pire dans
4 milliards d'années l'humanité disparaît
sous
la géante solaire rouge et on sera sûr
qu'il n'y a plus d'extraction de pétrole mais
bien avant ça s'arrêtera
et entre ceux-là tu auras un
maximum absolu qui s'appelle le
pic  et ce pic a lieu pour l'
extraction du pétrole mais aussi pour la
fonction carbone cuivre talium bore vanadium
chrome
etc dès que vous sortez quelque chose de la
croûte terrestre et que vous démarrez et
t  qu'il a un start stop donné une fois
pour toutes vous aurez un maximum annuel d'extraction
de cette ressource
en décembre 2018 l'agence internationale de l'
énergie a publié un rapport que vous
pouvez voir ici sur lequel il est explicitement
écrit que
et bien sûr la presse française a
à peine parlé mais le maximum
pour l'extraction du
pétrole dit conventionnel c'est à dire ce qui n'est ni
shell oil aux états-unis ni oil
sense au canada a
été passé en 2008. qui dans cette salle en a
entendu parler
peut en voir trois  quatre huit d'accord
je peux vous dire que c'est nettement
plus structurant pour le système de retraite
que les négociations qui
se déroulent actuellement en france
dont on nous parle nuit et
jour
parce que cela structure le montant total
de la trésorerie pour qu'il y ait à  répartis entre nous
et si le montant total d'argent défavorable
au partage diminue,
nous pouvons faire toutes les danses de la pluie que nous voulons sur la
promesse d'
augmenter le point d'indice de tout ce
qu'il n'y
aura pas plus  cash d'accord donc la
pagination du journal aurait dû
être inversée
nous aurions dû te parler toute la
journée de ça et de temps en temps
de ce qui se passe dans les
négociations de retraite
mais je t'assure que ça ne va pas
être le problème ton  les retraites même les miennes
votre problème ne sera pas
les négociations en
cours seront ceci si vous regardez
tout ce que nous pouvons sortir du
sol sous
forme liquide donc y compris shiloh etc je vais
faire court mais bon
fondamentalement le maximum total  n'est pas 2008
mais dans les années 2020
et le pétrole est l'énergie la plus limitante
parmi toutes les énergies
car il contrôle le transport et ce que
vous pouvez voir ici
est la variation depuis 1965 de la
quantité de pétrole
que nous retirons du sol notez que
c'est la quantité non  le prix en rouge
et le pib par personne en bleu ce que
vous voyez c'est que depuis la crise pétrolière
on s'est limité au
maximum
avec ce qu'on peut faire sur le pétrole mais pour économiser
on a gratté effici  partout et
bien les deux sont parfaitement synchronisés et quand
il y a un décalage
c'est le pétrole qui varie avant le pib
donc ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a de la croissance qui
vient de mars
qu'on achète plus de pétrole c'est parce
qu'il y a plus de pétrole qu'il y a plus de
machines qui peuvent s'échanger
eux-mêmes donc la production augmente
et vice versa et il n'y a pas de lien
entre le volume et le prix en ce qui concerne le pétrole,
c'est donc la deuxième chose que
vous pouvez apprendre ici qui est totalement
fausse quand il s'agit de pétrole et en fait
totalement fausse quand il s'agit de lots  de
choses
vous avez ici un graphique où je
mets sur l'axe des abscisses la quantité de pétrole
achetée sur le marché par an
qui est essentiellement la quantité produite
et
ici le prix du baril si vous avez une
élasticité prix volume comme on peut l'apprendre
à l'école le point devrait être arrangé
comme la ligne bleue en pointillé comme
ça moins tu as plus cher
plus tu as moins cher c'est la
fameuse chose qu'ils t'apprennent à l'école
quoi  vous voyez ici ça ne ressemble à
rien quand il s'agit d'huile
vous avez une espèce de plat à spaghetti et en
fait si vous regardez l'historique
vous pouvez voir que depuis 50 ans vous avez un
volume qui varie considérablement avec un
prix qui reste constant
alors vous  avoir un volume qui ne
varie guère avec un prix qui devient fou
et même chose ici et ici vous
ne verrez pas la raréfaction du pétrole par le
fait que le prix
monte indéfiniment
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va le voir
venir vous allez  voir le pétrole
se raréfier
parce que les capex par baril extrait
par jour augmentent indéfiniment
c'est vrai mais pas le prix à cause
du pic de la production conventionnelle
en 2008
l'approvisionnement en pétrole de l'europe est contraint
depuis 2006.
je vais accélérer les choses un  un peu
parce que l'horloge pense ainsi en
europe l'approvisionnement en pétrole est aujourd'hui limité
l'approvisionnement en gaz en europe a commencé à diminuer
en 2005
parce que la mer du nord qui nous fournit la
majeure partie de notre gaz a commencé à diminuer en
2005,
c'est le pic de production qui est
passé, la bobine diminue en
Europe depuis des décennies parce que cela fait deux
siècles que nous avons exploré
nos stocks de charbon, ce qui était bien avant que nous
commencions à nous occuper du changement climatique
et donc si vous ajoutez le charbon, le pétrole et le gaz qui
font  jusqu'à 75
% de l'approvisionnement énergétique de l'europe tout ce qui a
commencé à baisser
depuis 2006. vous ajoutez le nucléaire qui
est volontairement réduit pour de
mauvaises raisons à mon avis mais nous le faisons quand même
ce ne seront pas les nouvelles énergies renouvelables que
vous avez ici qui  compenser cette
diminution de manière significative
, vous voyez donc sur ce graphique trois parties pour
l'approvisionnement énergétique par personne en Europe d'
abord jusqu'à la crise pétrolière, il y a une
augmentation,
cela commence en ce moment, mais les
économistes commencent à dire où la
productivité est-elle
allée bien la productivité est entrée  le fait
que l'énergie, c'est-à-dire le nombre de
machines en fonctionnement par personne,
a cessé de croître, c'est là que la
productivité est allée
quand vous avez 40 ans quand elle  est
constant et l'économie se débat un
peu la dette augmente la productivité
n'augmente pas à mesure que
le chômage commence à augmenter rapidement,
etc.  commence vraiment à
monter sur les rails la dette explose le chômage
commence à augmenter de manière significative vous
commencez à avoir une inflation des actifs partout
lorsque vous commencez à faire de l'assouplissement quantitatif,
etc.
et vous voyez des taux négatifs monter
fondamentalement le système
déraille vraiment et ce n'est que
le début
et  si vous regardez la variation du pib
par
personne sur ces trois périodes vous
voyez qu'avant
quand l'énergie par personne augmente
rapidement
nous par an quand l'énergie arrête de
croître on n'est plus qu'à
deux et il y a déjà un début d'
inflation des actifs et depuis 2006  nous sommes
presque à zéro et vous demandez aux britanniques et
s'ils aiment ça et ils disent non
en ce qui concerne le climat l'
idée principale de ce que je vais faire  eh bien vous
tenez dans cette carte vous avez ici une
représentation des écosystèmes
installés en europe avant le début
du changement climatique donc c'est à dire
au milieu du 20ème siècle
ce que vous voyez c'est que si vous prenez les
écosystèmes et vous ne le faites pas  enlevez-les pour
faire plein de choses futiles comme des
champs et des routes ou des choses essentielles
comme le campus de cette université
eh bien vous avez essentiellement des forêts
donc ça veut dire que partout en europe
il pleut assez pour faire pousser de
grosses espèces végétales qui sont des arbres
voici à quoi ressemble l'europe 20 000
ans  il y a donc il y a 20 000 ans évidemment
cette université n'existe pas les
humains sont un peu moins nombreux et nous
sommes au coeur de la dernière ère glaciaire
donc il fait beaucoup plus froid qu'aujourd'hui on le
prétend très spontanément l'homme n'est pas le
seul qui  rend le climat berry
nous le faisons très très vite trop vite mais
il varie
plus lentement naturellement et donc vous voyez
que la géographie européenne
ne ressemble en rien à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui donc
il n'y a pas plus loin à l'étranger dans s  weden alors
oubliez ça
car la scandinavie est recouverte de
trois kilomètres de glace
exactement comme canada tabernacle comme vous
diriez
puisque cette glace s'est formée en prenant de l'
eau
là où elle est disponible c'est à dire dans
l'océan et que le fond de l'
océan
n'en a pas  changé parce que c'est toujours
au même endroit
le niveau de l'océan a baissé de 120 mètres
donc vos grands-parents n'auraient pas perdu
toutes leurs économies dans le tunnel de l'euro
il n'y avait pas besoin de construire ce
tunnel de l'euro entre la france et le royaume-uni parce que le
canal n'est tout simplement pas là  plus
ce stoneboros attrapé et le rugby plus
les irlandais le font encore malheureusement
il fait beaucoup plus froid et donc beaucoup
plus sec
et vous n'avez pas de forêt presque pas de forêt
en europe tout ce que vous avez c'est marcher dans la toundra
dans ce genre d'écosystèmes que vous parvenez à
maintenir en vie 100
000 bons  hommes en france donc la
population française à l'époque est
un petit quartier persan quand la terre est
passée de
la dernière période glaciaire à l'ère pré-industrielle
l'ecosy  les tiges en europe sont passées
de ceci
à ceci et évidemment la température
s'est réchauffée
et bien le réchauffement climatique
correspondant à cette transition est de 5
degrés
en 10 000 ans avant de détailler
très rapidement les conséquences du
changement climatique rappelez-vous juste cette phrase conclusive
cinq degrés dans un  siècle, c'est la guerre
partout,
c'est exactement ça cinq degrés dans un
siècle, c'est la guerre
partout, cela signifie que la
déstabilisation des
conditions environnementales ira à
une telle vitesse
en plus de cela dans un monde qui, dans la
seconde moitié d'un siècle, commencera à
être dans un  état forcé de
contraction
énergétique c'est à dire avec moins de moyens pour réagir
à l'adversité
il est absolument évident que la façon dont
le système réagit
est en créant des conflits et des tensions
absolument partout
quelques exemples
ici vous avez le nombre de jours qui
seront létaux c'est à dire  dire
qu'il sera physiquement impossible de
survivre en l'an
2100 avec une hausse de température de quatre
degrés
la raison w  hy c'est tellement concentré près de
l'équateur c'est qu'il va faire tellement chaud dans
ces endroits avec une humidité
aussi élevée mais tu ne pourras pas transpirer pour
évacuer ta chaleur et tu vas mourir d'
hyperthermie
il fait trop chaud d'accord ben tu vois ça
dans  à certains endroits, ce sera toute l'année
ici 360 50 jours par an
voici un graphique issu du
dernier rapport du GIEC appelé changement climatique
sur la terre et il indique qu'à partir de
trois degrés d'augmentation de la température, il
y a une insécurité alimentaire largement répandue sur
toute la planète
et une insécurité alimentaire généralisée est une
violence généralisée
c'est une constante tout au long de l'histoire humaine le
groenland a commencé à fondre et l'
antarctique occidental est en danger de
déstabilisation si nous allons au-delà de la
trajectoire à deux degrés l'
antarctique occidental finira probablement par se
désintégrer
cela plus cela va être  neuf
mètres de plus dans l'océan dans quelques
siècles
donc ça fait quelques siècles mais le
doigt sur la gâchette est en ce moment
donc je ne détaillerai pas les conclusions  Je vais
juste terminer avec le dilemme que nous
avons
ici est une deuxième courbe importante qui
donne la réponse en température d'un
climat en fonction de la quantité totale de co2
que nous allons mettre dans l'
atmosphère entre l'ère préindustrielle
et la  année 2100 d'accord d'ici
fin 2018 2
200 milliards de tonnes de co2 ont été rejetées
dans l'atmosphère ce qui garantit une
hausse de température de 1,5 degrés
donc en fait les fameux 1,5 degrés dont
on parle parfois dans
les engagements politiques dans les
discours d'entreprises etc en
disant on va  faire le
nécessaire en fait on n'y peut rien
c'est déjà perdu si on veut les deux
degrés
qu'il faut pour limiter les
émissions cumulées d'ici
2100 à 3 000 milliards de tonnes de co2
dont
2 200 ont déjà été émises
qui  ça veut dire qu'en 2 100 on a encore
le droit d'émettre
un tiers de ce qu'on a déjà émis
dans le passé pas plus
alors qu'on va être en moyenne trois
fois plus nombreux sur terre
donc ça veut dire que le ca  l'empreinte carbone de
chaque personne, cette pièce doit représenter
un dixième de l'empreinte carbone de vos grands-parents
sur toute votre vie, ce sont les deux
degrés, ce
qui signifie également que d'ici 2050, vous devez
diviser les émissions mondiales par
gratuitement, ce qui est une autre façon de dire
qu'ils ont qu'ils
doivent diminuer de quatre pour cent par an, donc
tout plan d'affaires qui n'est pas compatible
avec une diminution de quatre pour cent par an
des émissions mondiales n'est pas
acceptable
en termes de préservation du climat
je peux vous dire que c'est à peu près n'importe quel
plan d'affaires que vous ferez
à peu près n'importe lequel d'entre eux donc la situation
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons est qu'aujourd'hui nous naviguons
entre
deux risques il y a un homme qui s'appelle mark
carney qui a publié ce
bien nous avons parlé de ces risques il y a à peine
trois ans juste avant la coupe 21.
soit nous ne  m'en fout à court terme
de contrôler les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
en disant tant qu'on pourra
profitons-en
et puis on aura tout de suite à cause
de l'inertie d'un système
qui  h ne pourra plus éviter les risques physiques
qui peuvent affecter l'espérance de vie d'une
grande partie d'une population sur terre
ou on va se serrer la ceinture très
très vite et dire
ça va comme ça on évitera
les risques climatiques majeurs
et on  sont à l'origine d'une récession mondiale majeure,
c'est soit l'un soit l'autre,
ce n'est pas à la fois le fromage et le dessert,
malheureusement,
dans cette affaire, les entreprises ont évidemment
un
rôle à jouer et je vais terminer
avec cela, vous savez aujourd'hui,
il y en a beaucoup, peut-être qu'il y en a
des gens dans cette salle qui ont signé le
manifeste des étudiants pour un
réveil écologique et je vais dire
des choses désagréables mais il y a beaucoup moins
de ces étudiants dans les écoles de commerce
que dans les écoles d'ingénieurs je me demande pourquoi
c'est comme ça et
sous ce manifeste  il y a
plutôt du côté manifeste il y a un
petit guide anti-green washing que je
vous conseille d'aller lire c'est marrant
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas une seule entreprise
qui ne vous dit pas sustai  nable
développement c'est vraiment important etc je
ferai tout pour être à deux degrés peu
importe et ainsi de suite
donc je dis ok ces gens peuvent me dire
exactement ce qu'ils veulent je ne crois
pas une seconde ce qu'ils me disent jusqu'à ce
qu'ils
aient au moins fait le  liste je vais
vous montrer maintenant
vous avez tous entendu
mille fois le changement climatique
vous l'avez peut-être entendu mille fois je
pense
qu'il y a encore très peu de personnes dans
cette salle qui sont
capables de me décrire exactement de quoi il s'agit
à propos de
cela signifie quels sont les ordres de
grandeur mais les constantes de temps les causes
les processus impliqués, etc.
ce que vous pensez être une solution est en fait
une goutte aléatoire
et lorsque vous tirez au hasard la
probabilité que vous atteigniez la
cible est extrêmement faible
aujourd'hui c'est exactement ce qui se passe
dans le monde économique
et politique qui signifie t  chapeau les
gens qui prennent des décisions ont un manque de
connaissances
sur le problème qui se pose ce qui est majeur
notamment pour les raisons magiques
mais pas seulement et donc ils tirent
au hasard
mon avis personnel est que pour commencer à
comprendre ce qui se passe avec les
histoires que j'ai brièvement  touché ce
soir il faut prendre
10 à 30 heures puisque le
carbone n'est pas présent dans les euros
vous n'êtes pas
capable de comprendre à quelle distance vous êtes
du problème tant que vous n'avez pas un
système comptable qu'il soit adapté
aux problèmes à traiter  avec ainsi votre
comptabilité monétaire ne vous dit
absolument rien sur où vous en êtes
avec la question climatique
rien de tel jusqu'à ce qu'une entreprise ait fait
une comptabilité carbone détaillée qui permet à
chaque responsable de l'entreprise,
c'est-à-dire vous dans quelques années, de
pouvoir comparer le monétaire et le
carbone  caractéristiques de la décision
à prendre
vous n'êtes pas équipé pour naviguer dans
un tel monde
et cela ne concerne quasiment aucune entreprise en
france il n'y en a quasiment aucune à ce niveau  est
niveau
alors je ne connais aucune entreprise à quelques
rares exceptions
qui a aujourd'hui une stratégie à long terme bien
quand ils ont des stratégies à long terme de
nos jours c'est assez étonnant
mais a une stratégie à long terme qui est
compatible avec une baisse de quatre pour cent
par an en émissions ce qui veut dire
que ça contraint très vite
la disponibilité les moyens de
transport disponibles les moyens de
production disponibles le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs avec des localisations géographiques
qui restent accessibles etc
évidemment il faut regarder toute
la chaine de valeur je ne connais quasiment aucune entreprise
qui a fait cela
quand les entreprises disent qu'elles vont
fixer des objectifs, elles les prennent généralement par
unité de production,
alors elles disent que je vais bien réduire
comme généralement des amis de l'air l'autre jour,
je vais réduire les émissions de vmi par
passager-kilomètre
mais en même temps, ils veulent que leurs
passagers-kilomètres augmentent plus rapidement
que l'unité diminuant les émissions,
je n'appelle pas cela résoudre le problème si
vous dites que je  Je vais boire moins par heure,
mais beaucoup plus souvent,
il n'est pas complètement exclu que votre
foie
s'aggrave de toute façon et enfin
le processus doit être piloté, donc si vous
n'avez pas
pour ces questions un membre exécutif de la communauté qui
dépense à  moins 25 pour cent de son temps,
alors il est traité de manière désinvolte
le dernier point est que dans toutes les entreprises
qui ont des parts variables
et il y en a beaucoup si cette question
n'est pas dans les parts variables alors
le sujet n'est pas traité
sérieusement  donc ici,
je vous donne à tous un très petit sous
-ensemble parce qu'il y a évidemment beaucoup
plus que ce
qui est essentiel pour qu'une entreprise
commence à prétendre qu'elle fait
des choses sérieuses sur la question
alors qu'elle n'a pas fait tout cela  ça
m'intéresse même pas de bien écouter ça
m'intéresse de travailler avec lui c'est mon
boulot
mais je n'accorde presque aucune crédibilité à
ces déclarations publiques de ses
vertus autoproclamées là je suis à la fin de mon temps
je'  ll  stop
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci monsieur jean-marc
jean-claude d'être venu ce soir